I love being called out on my [ __ ] then
you're gonna love this friendship from
the hip I always know right where you
stand
yeah which is usually you know with your
foot on the back of my neck cuz I'm
drowning too graphic
no it's alright I could even go more
graphic I've never seen you laugh harder
and when you described how you would
kill me
yes because you think my laugh is loud
and I know much so do you remember what
you said um well I know it involved a
shovel and and burying you alive I think
I have the exact quote I just imagined
burying you alive throwing a shovel full
of dirt into your mouth during that
laughs you know what out of pity I would
clunk the shovel on your head to put you
out but then I would Jam dirt into your
mouth and use the backside of the shovel
to just jam it all the way down your
throat I want to remember but it is fun
to imagine every human s close friends
look I want to drive off a mountain
myself oh yeah yeah that's just a bare
minimum you know sure but that was nice
that I did clunk you out of conscious
yeah that would that's what makes me a
friend as opposed to an enemy you
haven't done your characteristic laugh
yet so it feels hard to reference sure
why I would want to throw dirt into that
that's like such a small laugh for you
that's it now you're in the zone I told
me to wrap it up but we had talked about
flip-flop nation
I got a chick do we have some I sweat on
the card and I was alone in my office
and I'm like any second I don't even
think anyone's going to like this or
appreciate me neither great place to end
then great choice flip-flop nation yes
is whenever you see me wearing
flip-flops and you're wearing flip-flops
you go we are in the nation
we call it the flip-flop nation shout
out to anyone at home who may be in the
nation right now anyone in the audience
in the nation currently one in Asia
so cold in here for the nations when I
wearing flip-flops I don't know why this
makes me so happy I'll just text you in
the nation you'll write back hashtag FFN
yeah and it just makes me so happy I
wanted to share that little piece of
joke and we need to take over that
hashtag cuz I discovered it stands for
something else
FFN yeah but I forget what so by
five-fingered Nazis yes
very quick on your feet this is gonna
come together come back I love you doing
ready